hello everybody welcome out to their
commentaries we are here to break down
Bladerunner 2049 in honor of played
round 2049 we're breaking down Blade
Runner 1982 with Joestar hi
Spencer J Gilbert Nina so yeah this was
obviously fitting time to do it because
they just released the sequel which is
really good I liked a lot you did saw to
you'd like to do I really really enjoyed
um who would have thought whether it's
better or worse it will be a debate for
the ages which I look forward to having
but let's focus on the original which
two I'll be I'll start I wasn't big a
fan I mean I'd like to buy respect it I
respect its shot really well but I some
of those movies that as a kid I was like
oh man I gotta watch Blade Runner over
and over again where did you guys stand
with it in your seas I saw Blade Runner
way too late to care about it as much as
I think I'm supposed to so I'm probably
like a bad film fan I guess maybe but
yeah I saw it once I'd already seen
everything I did you hired a theatrical
I know of directors yeah I saw the
directors to first and then I watched
the phone cut Spencer yeah I liked it a
lot I don't remember the first time I
saw it but I remember that it wasn't
what I expected I wouldn't say it was
like oh that was like walking out Star
Wars they're so entertaining I want to
dress up like Deckard but it was it was
something that stuck with me that like I
kind of thought about it or like kept
images in my head for for my whole life
so it definitely made an impression I'll
agree with you on the images it did it
did had the same issue it's the neon
billboards and stuff damn its ponderous
it really is as Blade Runner 2049 is
also very ponderous yeah in rewatching I
had kind of forgotten it is a little
slower than I'd remembered not to that's
a bad thing but it is not you know it
just kind of go it's a really weird
movie it just kind of goes it doesn't
really have a straight through line it
just kind of is there and then it's not
there yeah with tight plot plotted like
something happening every every other
second it's just kind of like a
meandering like investigation that kind
of brings up some interesting questions
it's easy it's easy to see why Hollywood
panicked
and through in voiceover what it was
going into the theaters although that
does because this is so so much an or
movie like based on like the private
dick you know in between good and evil
and one of the tropes of that was the
voice sorcerer yeah it should voice over
explaining everything but Harrison Ford
apparently just hated the idea so much
right or was is that the story that he
just purposely tried to tank his reads
on the voice-over it's bad well he's I
think his thing was he was like I mean
it was so terrible how could you deliver
it good
hmm calm be calm don't make all these
bad scripts have been done good by
actors well yeah to me it's also it
feels like almost like Episode four and
a bigger series then I come back and
look at it like I it's not as
complicated as I thought it was when I
want rewatched I'm like it's pretty
simple story it is like a detectives
trying to find four robots and falls in
love sort of can consensually and then
tracks the robots down and then you know
that's sort of the movie now there are
some broader stuff visual and thematic
yeah there's like sort of put it off the
games like oh no it's complicated I'm it
but it's not very complicated my story
is pretty easy it's just a little slow
and it's a thinking piece of but that's
why I liked the new one not to get it
but it's like I feel like the new one
takes that and then builds up a bigger
some more themes and layers and
questions but in watching just one by
itself it definitely is a it's a strong
skeleton of something but I feel like I
still needed some more meat on it for me
to be as excited but visually amazing
and good critic Rutger Hauer right crazy
yeah we also kind of a line that might
be in the deleted scenes but I love the
the soundtrack of like the gritty spa
music the place the whole thing just
kind of crunchy synth drums and
saxophone yeah yeah there was that well
we'll get there but yeah there was
almost a hidden track we were gonna make
but they never happened
we're gonna spoil it now but the stairs
run we were gonna do that like the
Twilight stairs done great ambition is
what's called right down
dun dun dun dun dun dun dun don't so
we're gonna do the Vangelis pas version
of it's never happened we have enough
time but we're gonna try and composing
they slowed dares and jealous version of
it and it never happened
shall we watch it guys let's watch it
[Music]
from the visionary director well he
makes big visionary hits or big
ambitious disasters comes the clunky cut
of his 80s classic improved by a
director's cut 10 years later and
further refined by his final cut in 2007
sterile ha she's pretty good to go
Ridley sure you don't want to go home
that's what the ending again throw the
voice of the back in and history books
he's the kind of cop used to call black
men
Blade Runner in London Tunis audiences
new Harrison fool as the charming rogue
Han Solo or the charming rogue Indiana
Jones now watch him ditch the whole
charming act in the grumpiest Harrison
for performance since any time he's
forced to promote a movie this 135 years
after the original
so what serious drinking problem
drink drink I get you a drink if he's a
robot then what is this doing anything
the he subway rotor part bounty hunters
they have sensations they have you have
cells yeah and a lot of some of them
don't know that they're replicants so
yeah I think it's we you are right the
sexes are your Inlet the fluids coming
out would sort of tell him whether he's
a replicant or not wouldn't it no
they're very realistic yeah it went
really out of their way
indistinguishable meatbags to go be
cannon fodder yeah and if these programs
and how would he know what's normal and
what's not normal to him it's normal but
he'd probably see someone else pee yeah
at some point oh you peed because I do
you will this is my biggest problem with
the concept of this movie because it's
like if you just want cannon fodder to
go being Wars and then also to have sex
with all knees look go make little gray
cubes to go shoot guns and also I think
men have proved they will probably also
have sex with a great cube I think again
that kind of goes away from the plot
element of the movie and more into the
thematic thing about Tyrell and his
whole thing was creating life and drew
and perfecting it and making the perfect
organism and and issues of God and
creation and when Rutger Hauer visits
them it's very kind of Adam confronting
his creator and so I think that's
probably why they're a little more
realistic but do you think it still
would have been had the same impact if
he was a small I don't think it would
have had the same in like wall-e I don't
think to disagree
I don't think tears in rain would have
been as good with water on a great a
little bit of its power time to dive
stick instantly making Morse code make
that super cut Blade Runner with actual
robots yeah yeah I think we found it on
a scene freeze pen said great new in
line is robot costume with a Roomba yeah
yeah girl suddenly realized there's a
wasp crawling on your arm - OH - Blade
Runner shut up
justification there's an out of universe
explanation I think for in like Bart -
the philip k dick novel that this is
based on a short story or whatever yeah
that like it was slang for robots like
like like that they were called blades
but none of that made it into the movie
kind so that was a plane running I think
don't quote me on that but I think that
it has more to do with like Phillip K
dicks world which is very different by
the way a lot more stuff about like
owning a fake animal seems to be like
the main thrust of the story which also
is the theme of like what's alive and
what isn't but people are obsessed with
like he only takes on the job so he can
like buy his wife like a robot dog so
they also have this really cool feature
that did make it in where they dial up
moods on like a like a keyboard they can
like people just decide what mood they
want to be in and like there there's all
this like farcical married couple fights
between decorative his wife or they're
dialing in different moods to have for
each other which is a very different
movie but also cool yeah it's like
putting on Spotify basically nowadays
yeah yeah okay good a lot ideas Siri be
happy yeah be happy my tears in right it
sounds cool he'll struggle with the
morality of killing things that seem to
be alive but he won't struggle with the
morality of porking them against their
will I mean it's okay cuz they're both
robots is he a robot Spencer something
that's not how consent works hunts
robots known as replicas soldiers and
sexbots built with false memories those
aren't your memories there's somebody
else an upgrade is cruel and pointless
as giving your fleshlight a family
history and witness the break-up
performance that's like a letter k to
speak to itself all those moments will
be lost in time like tears and rain
literally the only time that's work
since Apocalypse Now
[Music]
I'm so happy that we a can do a trailer
for Blade Runner and be doing Apocalypse
Now snow Bladerunner writing your own
dialogue joke we've earned it we didn't
have Twilight trailer clear make your
hair line again I never really noticed
that but look do you think he's given
that smile because he's like yeah that
was good murk after he said the Alliance
like reliving like the law good moments
of his life time he's looking at Dekker
right there I've always had a theory
that he knows that his Deckard is a
replicant and so going through his dying
thing that that in his mind he's like
you don't even know like you don't even
know this is gonna happen to you or that
that you should be treasuring your life
as much as I treasure mine again that's
the one of the things about Blade Runner
is it doesn't give you those answers and
and I think why a lot of people don't
connect to it as much as like it's it's
it's you have to bring a lot to it and
you can't you know that's why we're dumb
Joe that's one of those movies that you
know yeah I guess yeah oh and a clever I
like this movie I just saw everything
and inspired first so I sort of junk
hearted it for myself
yeah yeah yeah where I was like oh cool
yeah scene goes the show way better yeah
yeah it is Ghost Michelle no I agree I
do like what they don't make the
Harrison Ford Izzy replicant like so
clear-cut that definitely makes the film
better for making you sort of find your
own version of it which we are 17
different versions yeah and helpful
yes it's a little different yeah it's
like people to see Citizen Kane and
sleep oh he's obviously heard of a model
on back projections like he invented it
[Applause]
that's why that movies so great sooner
before like yeah no one else had before
that yeah that's why people think it's
amazing but because there now I've seen
it before was that first clip that was
ever like predictors like the train the
check freaked out it was like it guys
like hoops and trains they hadn't
history's whatever it's a lot of thing
since Apocalypse Now and Savior film
that saves its biggest twist for last
Deckard might be a replicant to morgue
is he maybe it's pretty subtle and
depends on the God ever take that test
yourself whatever everyone acts like a
sad robot anyway that Harrison Ford
didn't think he was playing replicant
and like fought Ridley Scott on it even
after the movie came out because
Harrison Ford wasn't playing it that way
I'm not a robot yeah even though people
point to moments like that's like a
robotic way to deal with that question
but he was playing it as like a private
investigator I was tired I was tired and
jerky that's not how replicants work
yeah so justify Harrison Ford didn't
think he was a replicant yeah I know it
for the whole debate still going and
I'll be interesting to see how they
handled it in twenty forty nine you know
at one point in his life between 1982
and today someone's come up to Harrison
Ford and said like scuse mr. Ford I'm
sorry to bother you it's like I just
have to know are you a replicant and he
was just like I don't give a [ __ ] it's
make-believe I'm buying a hammer you
tell Ridley Scott psych Dave Cleo and
they're like is that the last Morissette
song about you I'm sure they ask him
that all the keys nest and Harrison Ford
also buying tools to do down the rabbit
all the Dave Coulier which kind of bled
runner is I said
the book we agreed to think because this
low ass movie is gonna give you plenty
of time for that as you spend hours
staring at old photographs montage but
it's not really a stairs run it's
different from the actual stairs
staring at our music is always to us
that's the music library service fees
and staring at Deckard staring at the
window of his car
a lot of this between every see it's
kind of fair what else is he gonna do
well you don't have to show every moment
of his life and the movie don't seem go
bathroom that's an experience a visual
masterpiece that influenced countless
animes cyberpunk filled bossa nova Joe
do you want to talk about this cyberpunk
debate yeah we were not well versed in
cyber pumpkin there were some choices
that Joe had to school us on cyberpunk
you know the Terminator actually we're
doing things like Terminator 2 cyberpunk
I don't know if it is I think
post-apocalyptic sci-fi I know it's
nerdy but I would rather just not have a
zillion comments under this YouTube
that's like the Terminator cyberpunk
film you had strange days you're right
there and it's like let's just throw
strange days ever there is such like an
80s book genre that I feel like oh
absolutely it's only the old nerds that
would get upset about that and there's
I'm sure there's plenty of them that are
like no mention of tech war is Robocop
cyberpunk yeah I think so
I think you need like urban decay in a
near-future technology with technology
and just a gradient okay
mmm see to me it's a lot of like like
hacking and mainframes and stuff is
hackers is big
cyberpunk to me cuz hackers countless
linked rabbit ear brands and hackers oh
my some hackers being yeah there's a
cyberpunk movie yeah yeah yeah hackers
would be a good time it's not quite
Sipho ailment yeah it is I mean that
movie could have been called cyber punks
and it would be the same yes yeah I
think it counts as much to do with
hacking Johnny pneumonic virtuosity
virtuosity yeah the lawnmower man yeah
okay well the adaptation not the book
that nothing to do it I can't say movie
this cuz thank you do not imagine that
holds up and then the rain hacking they
do and then there's soldier the Kurt
Russell movie who Paul which Anderson is
he Paul WS Anderson all WS Anderson
insist that it's in the Bladerunner
universe because he loves Blade Runner
so much sounds like a legal liability
yeah but remembering vennett the one
part I remember about is like they had
Sandra Bullock like order a pizza and
like watch TV on her computer to like
show that she's like really sad and
lonely it's like that's 95 in the back
and I was like you loser ordering food
on your internet so accurate because now
we're doing that and we're all sad and
broken yeah I think I was like 13 when
that movie came out so I just remember
her like being in a bra on the trailer
be like yes yeah it's right off speed
yeah yeah popular all right 56 Kay's
just and all those times someone says
enhance at a screen over and over again
the center daddy's bright and shiny
sci-fi this one has rain and cigs and
hookers and stuff and forget about
plucky rebels fighting the evil empire
this one's about corporations menacing
life-threatening cells and if that's too
dark for you at least the umbrella
sticks light up those are goo
hello we so enjoy this story that sees
so clearly into the future predicting
our modern anxieties about genetic
engineering corporate ownership and
Ridley Scott's unicorn fetish forms in
half
that may not have done well at the box
office but broke the all-time record for
the number of film geeks insisting it's
genius
alright come on guys it looks amazing at
all but this is film noir with robots if
it was perfect they wouldn't have recut
it a hundred times
true cause can we just go back to the
nose guy if I if I was just had a weird
brain thing at that time but when they
go up to that when she goes up to that
guy's apartment his most elusive job and
he's got all those things he's having
sex with all those things right yes he
was definitely doing something that's
like boy it's like Michael Jackson like
he's childlike things sounds like he's
having sex like an innocent like he's
too childlike to even maybe it's creepy
it's definitely creepy but I don't think
he was having sex with but I don't know
I just that one in particular just wears
that nose good is wise like mouth like
particular just felt weird and I just I
didn't know if like I was just in a
weird mood or in fact there was another
edge to this movie that I hadn't thought
of previously while watching it but it
just seems like a mustache where do you
think he earned all those medals oh I
don't know maybe maybe I just just hit
me strangely but I this has a creepier
feel to it than I recalled I wish this
had better run in the trailer now asking
deep questions I imagine he was he was
owning the robots but you know why it's
his right mm life he can have sex with
I think or are they I'm not passing
judgment necessarily I just I think the
question popped into my head the reason
that the show exists is to ask these
questions
ya know save space Dan yeah anyway I
well I think the answer is something
creepy was definitely happened something
strange he has a very strange
sensibility at the editor mode but I
could see Spencer's point the Michael
Jackson of it is e to innocent even no
it's exactly the kid the whole time
perhaps I don't know anyway that just
popped into my head and I had to get
that up but look at his face look at the
look on his face he's like another guy
just came in to have sex with noir with
robots if it was perfect
they wouldn't have recut it a hundred
times holy smokes story nice time
definitely she's a Billy Idol
wrinkle is Einhorn I know when his
Finkle yeah littering captain Adama
William eight Maisie
yeah four eyes oh I sex monkey God and
Los Angeles two years from now without
the flame inhale that was there you know
it's cool Harrison's rebooting all his
iconic roles but there's not much left
after Deckard how long until we get Ari
witness re regarding Henry air force to
actually I totally watch that I would
Tim kudos the brine ward who made those
awesome posters at the end around
although Air Force two is the vice
president's place so till what a great
movie vice prime minister vice president
get on this plane again I think it's
that works think of Air Force One is
blown up with the President and then
it's all the other existing president
here's my right this is the pitch think
we're running with you have all the old
presidents that I've for like a saying
they're flying the funeral and then the
plight of the blow and all that's left
is Air Force to gala presidents get on
Air Force two and they have to escape
quickly in Air Force two Harrison Ford
on board because he loves to like crash
place
yes you can't let him stew you have like
a but you stun cast all the old
presidents - so you have one writing
with Harrison Ford Bill Pullman yes
Tommy Whitmore from the ex-president we
have all the old presidency of Morgan
Freeman you tiny what's-his-name from
Fifth Element
it's like Oh Hector macho Camacho yes
Camacho it's like Las Vegas but they're
all presidents and of course one plane
we need the PCU and I don't mean the
nineties movie we need the presidential
Cinematic Universe the Air Force - I'm
so into that I love just Bill Pullman
and Harrison Ford as the old presidents
and the plane taking on new terrorists
now just maybe fogs
from west wing and just it's just Barton
cheese there's so much aren't you Bert
would be great yeah oh man Michael
Douglas as or Dave kevin kline
Sinbad and the kid from first kid yes
just swap out do a Las Vegas reunion and
swap out De Niro with Harrison Ford and
you got it done oh yeah I like that
then Sinbad in first kid that's I'm
sorry that's not negotiable for me can
be animated president from Simpsons
movie an animated president of sorts a
tiger they really thought they were
gonna predict that future he was gonna
change the last mountain where it
instead they got Trump all right okay
about takes
all while lulling you to sleep with a
score that's 90% spam users
Tunnel on fixed rate listen oh this is
exactly what's like a robber in Los
Angeles
nailed it I know it's tough Walker story
unknown if you a replica of what Oscar
Pistorius Harrison Ford he's got hair
film okay the fry Dutchman Benjamin
Button avoid little slow tonight is in
his bartender formation like a l'amour
replica douche
splash escapes without their maiden
splash Do Androids Dream of organic
unicorn different cuts of the movie get
not one of them has the sexy snake show
in it what a rip
I don't like the joke but we did it all
vo and the theatrical thing yeah
whatever but this guy just apropos of
nothing it just comes from nowhere
sounds like Anders from Ghostbusters
dingo he has big serpent I love it Peter
McNichol Jones now this commentator has
everything it's Harrison Ford
Oscar Pistorius Joe alright we really
really do have everything there it is
to enjoy tomorrow bugs we talked about
talked about a lot of things in this
episode but tell us what you thought
their comments below we'll be back every
Tuesday I guess these now come out on
Tuesdays it seems you were literally in
charge of this every Tuesday Australia
commentaries will break it down with you
and next week's me a fun one stay tuned
bye